اسعد الله صباحكم مشاهدينا بكل خير واهلا
بكم في هذه النشره المفصله من العربيه
نبدا من تطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث اعلن
مسؤول كبير مواليد لروسيا في مقاطع
دونيسكو ان الجيش الروسي خطا الامداد عن
اوغليدار وانه يستخدم مخطط نفسه الذي تم
فيسك وقال المستشار اجورا
لوكاله الروسيه قال انه يجري العمل على
الاستيلاء على مدينه
في حلقه نصف دائره من الشرق والجنوب
الشرقي مشيرا الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تواجه صعوبات لايصال الدعم والذخيره الى
المدينه بعد سيطره الجيش الروسي على مناطق
واسعه من اجليدار
هذا ورجح موحللون ان الهجوم الروسيه
القادم سيكون الاكبر منذ بدايه الحرب وفقا
لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه تقير
الصحيفه الغربيه اضاف ايضا ان موسكو قد
تستعد لفتح الجبهه جديده حيث تسعى لتقدم
قواتها عبر الحدود الروسيه لاستعاده
الاراضي التي طردت منها في صم او خارجي
بشمال شرقي اوكرانيا في حين تاهب سيما في
ظل معلومات ان موسكو تحشد نحو نصف مليون
جندي على الحدود وتكثف قصفها قبل ان تصل
دبابات والعربات المدرعه وانظمه الاسلحه
الاخرى من الغرب الى اوكرانيا
في هذا الاطار مشاهدينا قررت فرنسا تزويد
اوكرانيا بانظمه رادار للدفاع الجوي لتتبع
الصواريخ والطائرات بدون طيار في المنطقه
المحيطه بالعاصمه الاوكرانيه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني ووصف نظام الرادار جراوند ماستر
200 بانه فعال للغايه وسيقق ارواح
الاوكرانيين
هنا جرت احدى اهم معارك الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
وفي المكان ذاته روسيا تحتفل بذكرى هزيمه
الالمان وتستعرض قوتها العسكريه
العرض العسكري يوازيه حشد روسي شرقي
اوكرانيا تاهبا لشن اكبر هجوم منذ بدء
الحرب حيث تم حشد نحو 500 الف جندي لتنفيذ
هذا الهجوم او وفق وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
الذي توقع ان يبدا الهجوم تزامنا مع
الذكرى الاولى للحرب المخاوف الاوكرانيه
من حمله جديده
رافقها اقرار كييف بضغط روسي يستهدف الشرق
في ليمان وبخمود بخموت المحاصره بشرق
اوكرانيا يتركز القتال حولها بعد اكثر من
عشره شهور من المعارك الداميه التي
استنزفت الطرفين اما في منطقه دومباس
فتكثف روسيا حجم قواتها بشكل كبير سعيا
للسيطره عليها وتستعد موسكو لفتح جبهه
جديده حيث تسعى الى ان تتقدم قواتها عبر
الحدود الروسيه لاستعاده الاراضي التي
فلتت من قبضتها في سوم اوخر كيف
حشد مئات الالاف من القوات واستهداف عشرات
الاماكن يوميا استراتيجيه القوات الروسيه
بينما تقديرات المخابرات الاوكرانيه تشير
الى ان روسيا نشرت ما يقرب ب 30000 جندي
مؤخرا اوكرانيا التي تنتظر الدبابات
والعربات المدرعه وانظمه الاسلحه الاخرى
من الغرب تكافح للاحتفاظ بارضها على
امتداد 200 وخمسه وعشرين كيلومترا في
الشرق
عصام عبد السلام العربيه
طالب الرئيس الاوكراني بمنح فرصه حقيقيه
لبلاده لانضمام الاتحاد الاوروبي وقال انه
يعتقد ان اوكرانيا تستحق هذا العام الوصول
الى بدايه المفاوضات بشان عضويه الاتحاد
الاوروبي مؤكدا ان خطوه الاندماج مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي ستمنح الاوكرانيين
الطاقه والحافزه للقتال على الرغم من اي
عقبات وتهديدات على حد وصفه
اعلنت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسل ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي يعتزم انشاء مركز تنسيق
في مدينه الاهايه الهولنديه لجمع ادله
لمحاكمه روسيا بسبب النزاع في اوكرانيا
مضيفه انه سيتم انشاء مركز دولي في ذات
المدينه الهولنديه للتحقيق في الجرائم في
اوكرانيا على حد وصفها
كما اعرب برلمانيون من 20 دوله بينها
بريطانيا واوكرانيا وجورجيا وايسلندا
وكندا عن رغبتهم في حظر مشاركه الوفد
الروسي في اجتماع منظمه الامن والتعاون في
اوروبا المقرر عقده نهايه الشهر الجاري في
فيينا وكتب النواب في رساله الى السلطات
في النمسا انها مشاركه الوفد في مثل هذا
الوقت من شانها ان ترسل اشاره خاطئه الى
المجتمع الدولي وتعتبر بل تعتبر استفزازا
واضحا
اشارت وكاله رويترز الى ان الادعاء لعام
الامريكي قد يصادر ما يزيد على خمسه
ملايين دولار من رجل الاعمال الروسي
المقرب من الرئيس بوتين
مالوفيف ما قد يمهد الطريقه لاستخدام هذه
الاموال المساعده في اعاده بناء اوكرانيا
التي دمرتها الحرب وفخم ما ذكرت رويترز
وياتي ذلك بعد حكم صدر من محكمه منهات
الفيدراليه والذي يعد بمثابه اول امر
لمصادره عصور اموال روسيه منذ تشكيل وزاره
العدل فريق عمل يهدف الى الضغط على
الموارد الماليه لحلفاء الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين في عام 2022 ردا على الحرب
في اوكرانيا
ونواصل نشره من امريكا الشماليه حيث بدا
الراي العام هناك ينشغل بقصه رصد من طادين
صينيين احدهما في سماء الولايات المتحده
من جهه الغرب في ولايه مونتانا والاخر في
كندا التقارير الاستخباراتي الاولى تشير
الى ان المطاضين ذوات طابع تجسسي وحتى
الان لم تعلق الصين على ذلك
في هذا السياق مشاهدينا اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الكنديه في بيان انها تراقب من
طابه تجسس صينيا مشبوها هو الثاني بعد رصد
منطاد فوق الولايات المتحده مشيره الى ان
الاجهزه المعنيه رصدته على ارتفاعات عاليه
وانها تقوم حاليا بتتبع تحركاته بشكل فعال
واكد بيان وزاره الدفاع ان كندا تتخذ كافه
الخطوات اللازمه لضمان امن مجالها الجوي
كما كشفت ان كلا من قياده الدفاع الجوي
لامريكا الشماليه ووزاره الدفاع وشركاء
اخرين يعملون على تقييم الوضع بتنسيق وثيق
مؤكده انها تواصل العمل على اتخاذ جميع
الاجراءات اللازمه لحمايه المعلومات
الحساسه لكاندا من تهديدات المخابرات
الاجنبيه
قبل ذلك اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
انها تراقب منطاضا صينيا يعتقد ان بكين
اطلقته للتحليق فوق سماء الولايات المتحده
بهدف التجسس وقال مسؤول امريكي ان المنطقه
الصينيه هدفه التجسس وجمع المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه مضيفا ان واشنطن كانت تتعقب
المنطاد منذ دخوله المجال الجوي الولايات
المتحده قبل يومين وتفحصته عن قرب من خلال
طائرات عسكريه امريكيه وقد اوصى كبار
القاده العسكريين الامريكيين بعدم اسقاط
بالون التجسس الصيني فوق مونتانا بسبب
مخاطر السلامه المحتمله من الحطام
سيرين
تتفاعل اذا قضيه المنطاد الصيني قبيل
زياره مرتقبه لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي الى
بكين الاسبوع المقبل ليبحث ونظيره الصيني
ملفات مهمه بينها الازمه في تايوان
والسجلات حول الرقائق والتجاره الدوليه
وسط تسريبات تتحدث عن ان الوزيرين
سيحاولان التركيز على كيفيه تجنب اكبر
اقتصادين في العالم حربا بارده جديده رغم
توتر العلاقات بين واشنطن
هذا وحذر مدير وكاله المخابرات المركزيه
ويليامبرز من ان الصينه تمثل اكبر تحد
جيوسياسي يواجه الولايات المتحده وقال انه
من الخطا التقليل من خطوره العلاقات
الصينيه الروسيه مؤكدا ان الرئيس الصيني
متفاجئ ومصدوم من ضعف قدرات الجيش الروسي
وحول الصراع في تايوان انه سيكون له عواقب
وخيمه على جميع الاطراف ويجب عدم التقليل
من طموحات الرئيس الصيني لسيطره على
تايوان والتعامل معها بجديه وكشف مدير
وكاله المخابرات المركزيه ان الرئيس
الصيني يواجه الكثير من المشكله الداخليه
في بلاده
طالب اعضاء في الكونجرس الامريكيه رئيس جو
بايدن بربط بيع مقاتله اف 16 لتركيا
بالسماح الانضمام فنلندا والسويد حلف
الناتو عدم وضوح موقف انقره من انضمام
الدولتين الاوروبيتين للحلف وكان رئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان طالب الولايات
المتحده بتنفيذ وعدها وتسليم انقره طائرات
اف 16 واف 35 محذرا من ان هناك مقابل
للتصرفات الامريكيه
السياق مشاهدينا قالت رئيسه الوزراء
الفنلنديه سالامارين ان بل قالت ان فنلندا
والسويد قدمت معا الطلبه للانضمام الى
النيتو
اعتقد انه من المهم جدا ان نرسل اليوم
رساله واضحه فنلندا والسويد قدمتها طلبا
معا ومن مصلحه الجميع ان انضم الى النيتو
معا نحن على اتصال وثيق جدا بشكل يومي
بهذا الشان فنلندا والسويد الصوفيان كل ما
يلزم للحصول على العضويه بالطبع نريد من
تركيا والمجر ايضا التصديق على طلبينا في
اقرب وقت ممكن وبالطبع نحن على اتصال وثيق
جدا بهذا الشان انا
مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي يفتش منزل
النائب الرئيس الامريكي السابق بحثا عن
وثائق السريه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد متابعه
الاحتجاجات في ايران قال مدير وكاله
المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه ويليامبرز
ان الحكومه الايرانيه اصبحت غير مستقره
بشكل متزايد بسبب ما يحدث داخل البلاد
مشير الى شجاعه من وصفهن بالنساء
الايرانيات اللائس اما الانتهاكات واعمال
العنف والقمع
في هذا الاطار مشاهدينا طالبت بريطانيا
واستراليا ايران بوقف اعدام المتظاهرين
واقامع الاحتجاجات كما اذان البلدان في
بيان مشترك توفير طهران اسلحه لروسيا
وتعهد وزراء الخارجيه والدفاع في البلدين
بمواجهه مساله توفير ايران لاسلحه تساعد
روسيا في حربها على اوكرانيا واتفق
الوزراء على مواصله العمل مع الشركاء
الدوليين بمحاسبه ايران من خلال وسائل
تشمل العقوبات
كشفت ايران تناسنا لنقلا عن مواقع اعلاميه
محلي ان النظام الايراني امر بتحليق
مروحيات عسكريه فوق عدد من المساجد في
زهدان وسط انباء عن تجديدات امنيه بعد
اعتقال مستشار خطيب الجمعه واضافت ايران
انترناشونال ان القوات الامنيه الايرانيه
كثافه حمله الاعتقالات العشوائيه في مناطق
زهدان خوفا من اتساع رقعه الاحتجاجات
المشتعله في البلاد منذ سبتمبر الماضي
بعد اكثر من اربعه اشهر من الاحتجاجات
المتاعب التي يواجهها النظام الايراني
تتفاقم تسجيل صوتي جديد للمساعد السابق
لمؤسسه الرئاسه الايرانيه بحكومه روحاني
محمد رضا صالحي وفي اجتماع المحافظين
الاخير كشف مخاوف من الانهيار الداخلي
للنظام مطالبا بتحديد صلاحيات خامنائي بما
في ذلك بندولايات المطلقه
يجب توجيه المرشد بخصوص الظروف الحاليه
والمستقبليه للبلاد المرشد يبلغ من العمر
نحو 80 عاما حتى لو عاش بعد 100 عام اخرى
هناك نهايه من سيجرا على اجراء الاستفتاء
ستتعطل العديد من قوانيننا وهي معطله الان
من الضروري تقويه البعد الاشرافي للقياده
وتقليص نطاق صلاحياته التنفيذيه من
الضروري تعديل الدستور على اساس تقويه
اركان الجمهوريه وتعزيز حق الشعب في
السياده من خلال الانتخابات وزياده
صلاحيات المؤسسات والمنتخبين والخاضعين
للمساءله في اثناء ذلك الاحتجاجات في كل
المناطق لا تهدا ففي ابضنان بمحافظه ايلام
غربا رفع المحتجون شعار الموت للديكتاتور
واغلق الشوارع باشعال النار ليلا وفي
محافظه اصفهان ايضا ردد المحتجون شعارات
مناوئه للنظام ليلا قابلت ذلك حمله
اعتقالات واسعه شامله نطاقها كل جغرافيا
البلاد ما لا يقل عن
367 مواطنا بلوشيا وكرديا تم اعتقالهم من
قبل قوات الامن الايرانيه خلال شهر يناير
المحاكمات هي الاخرى لا تتوقف 14 محتجا
تمت احالتهم على المحكمه لتهام قتل عنصر
من الباسج في طهران ويواجهون احكاما قد
تقودهم الى حبل المشنقه بلال البشتين
العربيه
دعما للاحتجاجات الشعبيه اطلقت منصه
سبوتيفاي الشهيره قائمه تشغيل اسمتها نساء
ايران وذلك لدعم اصوات النساء في البلاد
التي تشهد احتجاجات منذ مقتل الفتاه
الايرانيه مهس اميني ونقل
ان قائمه التشغيل ستتضمن اغاني لمغنيات
ايرانيات شهرات الى جانب مغنين اخرين
كانوا قد تعرضوا للاعتقال بسبب مشاركه
اغنيات تدعم الاحتياجات في ايران مثل
شريفين حاجيبور واتوماج صالحي كما ستوفر
سبوتيفاي ميزه المقاطع المرتبطه بقائمه
التشغيل والتي ستتيح منصه للموسيقيين
والكوميديين الايرانيين للتحدث عن موضوعات
الثقافه والفن وحريه التعبير
وقعت السعوديه وفرنسا مذكره تفاهم لوضع
اطار للتعاون في قطاع الطاقه وتشجيعه بين
البلدين وزير الطاقه السعوديه الامير عبد
العزيز بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز بحث مع
وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
للطاقه الذريه والفرص المستقبليه في مختلف
مجالات الطاقه وافادت وكاله الانباء
السعوديه ان مذكره التعاون في مجال الطاقه
بين فرنسا والسعوديه تتناول مجالات
التعاون في التعاون الرقمي وتوطين المواد
والمنتجات والخدمات المتعلقه بقطاعات
الطاقه وسلاسل الامداد
وفي اول زياره لمسؤول رفيع المستوى يمثل
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بعد تشكيل حكومه
السودان اختتم الامير فيصل بن فرحان زياره
وصفت بالمهمه الى العاصمه بغداد التقى
فيها نظره العراقي والرئاسه الثلاث من
جانبنا نحن نرحب بالشركات السعوديه
وبالاستثمار السعودي في العراق بهذه
العبارات استقبل وزير الخارجيه العراقي
نظيره السعودي في بغداد في اول زياره
لمسؤول
العربيه السعوديه
تخفيف حاله التواتر التوتر في المنطقه
والسعوديه كدوله
ودوله قاعده
في الاطار الاسلامي
تلعب دورا مهما في هذا المجال والعراق
كدوله محوريه في هذه المنطقه
نعمل معا
لتخفيف هذه التوترات الموجوده في المنطقه
وحل المشاكل عن طريق السلميه وعن طريق
الحوار ملفات الامن والاقتصاد والطاقه
تصدرت اجنقاءات علاقات ثنائيه متميزه مع
المملكه هكذا تصفها بغداد مع تاكيد واضح
من الجانبين على خفض التوتر في المنطقه من
خلال الحوار مع جميع الاطراف ولا اعمل
سويا
بتنسيق وثيق مع معاليكم لدفع عمليه
الاستقرار في المنطقه من خلال الحوار ومن
خلال
تعزيز المصالح المشتركه
معالجه اي اوجه خلاف وهذا مهم جدا لان لا
بدون الاستقرار لن نستطيع ان نحقق الرخاء
الذي نسى اليه زياره الامير فيصل بن فرحان
الى بغداد شملت ايضا الرئاسات الثلاث
المتمثله برئيس الجمهوريه ورئيس البرلمان
اضافه الى رئيس الحكومه جرت تاكيد من
خلالها على تطوير الشراكه الثنائيه وتوسعه
الاجتماعات من خلال مجلس التنسيق العراقي
السعودي وحل المشاكل العالقه في المنطقه
من خلال الحوارات الثنائيه سامر الكبيسي
العربيه بغداد
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه لاتفاق مع
اسرائيل على المضي قدما في تطبيع العلاقات
بين البلدين وقال بيان للوزاره ان وزيره
بل ان وزير الخارجي على الصادق التقى
نظيره الاسرائيلي في الخرطوم حيث تم
الاتفاق على تطوير علاقات البردين في
مجالات الزراعه والطاقه والصحه والمياه
والتعليم واضافت الخارجيه السودانيه انه
تم حث اسرائيل على العمل على تحقيق
الاستقرار والسلام للشعب الفلسطيني
من جانبه قال وزير الخارجي الاسرائيلي الى
كوهين ان زيارته للسودان ترسل اسس الاتفاق
سلام تاريخي وخلال مؤتمر صحفي عقب عودته
من الخرطوم اكد كوهين ان اتفاق السلام مع
السودان سيعز الاستخاره الاقليميه والامن
القوميه لاسرائيل فيما اوضحت وزاره الخارج
الاسرائيليه انهم من المنتظر التوقيع
واتفاق السلام مع السودان هذا العام في
واشنطن بعد تشكيل حكومه مدنيه
عاصمه السودان حيث قررت الدول العربيه
فيها اللاءات الثلاثه التاريخيه لا سلام
مع اسرائيل
ومفاوضات مع اسرائيل والاعتراف باسرائيل
نحن نبني واقعا جديدا مع السودانيين تصبح
فيه اللائات الثلاث نعم للمفاوضات بين
اسرائيل والسودان نعم للاعتراف باسرائيل
ونعم للسلام بين الدول والشعوب
انتقد البيت الابيض تصويت الجمهوريين في
مجلس النواب على قرار النقدي بعزل النائبه
الديمقراطيه الهان عمر من لجنه الشؤون
الخارجيه وقالت المتحدثه باسم البيت
الابيض كارين ان تصويت الجمهوريين بابعاد
النائبه عن عمر من لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه
هو حيله سياسيه معتبره ان اقاله
بارزين اخرين من اللجان الرئيسيين في
الاسابيع الاخيره اهانه للشعب الامريكي
هذا وصوت الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب
الامريكي على عزل النائب الديمقراطيه
الهان عمر من لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه محققين
نصرا لرئيس المجلس كيفن مكارثي الذي تعهد
منذ فتره طويله باقصائها من اللجنه
الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب الامريكي يقصون
النائبه الديمقراطيه الهام عمر من لجنه
الشؤون الخارجيه بتهمه معاداتها للساميه
التصويت جاء بعد نقاش حام اتهم خلاله
الديمقراطيون الجمهوريين بالنفاق
والعنصريه وبزدواجيه المعايير لوجود اعضاء
منهم استخدموا ايضا عبارات تعتبر معاديه
للساميه ولم يحاسبوا فيما القت عمر خطاب
الدفاعيا عن نفسها
[تصفيق]
البعض يرى ان سيارى رئيس مجلس النواب كمان
عمر من اللجنه خطوه رمزيه تشير الى انه
يفي بوعد انتخابيا قطعه سابقا لطردها اذا
فاز الجمهوريون باغلبيه مقاعد مجلس النواب
وكان منكر في اعلى تامين عدد اصوات كاف
لاستبعاد عمر واكد بعد عزلها انها لا يجب
ان تكون عضوا في اللجنه بسبب تصريحاتها
واضاف ان الجمهوريين لا يقصونها عن باقي
اللجان
فيما يتعلق بالنائب عمر ما قالته من
التعليقات المعاديه للساميه وان الجيش في
امريكا يساوي حماس وطالبان وانه في الحادي
عشر من سبتمبر حدث شيء ما في ذلك اليوم
حتى الرئيس الديمقراطي السابق للجنه يعتقد
ان تعليقاتها كانت خاطئه
الديمقراطيون اتهموا سابقا الجمهوريين
بانهم يريدون رد الكيل بمكيالين لطردهم
عضوي جمهوريين عندما الاغلبيه في المجلس
معتبرين ان التحرك لطرد النائبين
الديمقراطيين ادم شافوه من لجنه المخابرات
اضافه الى طرد عمر عملا انتقاميا سياسيا
حسين الطولد العربيه واشنطن
نشير المشاهدين الى هذه الاخبار العجله
نقنع عن الخارجيه الصينيه التي تقول ان لا
معلومات حاليا حول زياره وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه وتقول ايضا لا ننوا انتهاك
اراضي اي دوله او مجالها الجوي الخارجيه
الصينيه ايضا تتحدث عن المنطاد التجسس
الذي او بل من اكتشف هذا فوق امريكا
وكندا تقول يجب حل المساله بهدوء وحذر
وسنوافيكم بمزيد من التفاصيل حول هذا
الموضوع
الى سياق نشاطنا مشاهدينا حيث ذكرت وسائل
اعلام امريكيه نقلا عن مصادر مطلع انه من
المتوقع ان يجري مكتب تحقيقات الفيدرالي
تفتيشا لمنزل
في انديانا ومكتبه في واشنطن العاصمه بحثا
عن سجلات الناس سريه وقال صحيفه
العدل تتواصل مع الفريق القانوني لتحديد
موعد لتفتيش منزله في انديانا وربما مكتبه
في واشنطن
بعد عام على حادث رحيل الطفل المغربي ريان
في اقليم شفشاون بالمغرب اثر سقوطه في بئر
عاده الافراح اخيرا الى بيت اسره الطفل
الراحل باعلان قدوم مولود ذكر للعائله وفي
المستشفى المحلي في مدينه تطوان في شمال
المغرب وضعت الام وسيمه خرشيش طفلها وكان
الطفل المغربي الراحل ريان سقط في بئر ضيق
على عمق 32 مترا قرب منزل اسرته في الاول
من شهر فبراير من العام الماضي وهو الحادث
الذي شد انظارا وقلوب العالم
في نهايه النشر المشاهدين ان نذكر بعبرز
العناوين
القوات الروسيه تقطع خطوط امداد القوات
الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه دونيسكو وتتقدم من
ثلاثه محاور
يدعو لبدء مباحثات الانضمام الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي ويؤكد ان الاندماج سيحفز على
قتال روسيا
نهايه هذه نرسم مشاهدينا شكرا لحسن
المتابعه وكونوا بعافيها
[موسيقى]